hi my name is Andrea land worked for
shirt flow solutions today I'm going to
be talking about effectively utilizing
net link for application development
with the Wolfram language
my name is Andrew oh thanks you guys for
coming to my talk I'm gonna talk a
little bit today about application
development with the Wolfram language
and specifically how to utilize net link
and communicate with net this is kind of
a continuation presentation for me from
last year I kind of talked down a little
bit more of a broad topic about how to
develop applications with Wolfram
language specifically how to distribute
them with Enterprise CDF so this is
diving in a little bit more details on
that side of things so just a quick
outline we're gonna talk about
background motivation how I kind of came
about looking into some of this stuff
we'll talk a little bit about net and
then kind of the meat of the
presentation is gonna be broken up into
two parts the first part is gonna be
really quick though basically calling
Wolfram language from net and the second
part which I think is the real focal
point that's going to be calling dotnet
from the Wolfram language so just a
little bit about me my my background is
in chemical engineering yeah I work in
the oil and gas industry and I've been
using Mathematica and the Wolfram
language for my entire career so so six
years now so I work for a company called
the short flow solutions and we're
especially the engineering consulting
company and what we what we do is solve
production related issues in the oil and
gas industry we use kind of a
combination of two things one is a
simulation modeling to sort of simulate
fields and flow of oil and gas and water
through through pipelines and the other
thing that would we do is we have a
production chemistry lab where we can
actually take oil samples oiling to have
samples and run them through a variety
of tests to sort of characterize the
fluids and look at some types of issues
that you can have with production so
within within the oil and gas industry
what we do is is known as flow assurance
kind of sounds a little funny bit to the
outside industry but basically what
we're doing is assuring that you've got
flow of hydrocarbons and that's actually
a bit more difficult than it sounds
especially most of our work is offshore
so if you can imagine really harsh
environments you've got ultra deep water
you're producing from reservoirs that
are sometimes twenty thousand feet below
the surface so it gets pretty tricky
you've got a lot of really cold
temperatures high pressures and that
kind of creates an environment where you
can have a lot of production related
issues so this is here is an example of
if you have an oil sample that's got a
lot of asphaltenes in it under the right
conditions those asphaltenes will
precipitate out in your pipeline if it
gets bad enough it will completely block
your pipeline similarly here's here's
paraffin content this is this is long
saturated hydrocarbon chains that it'll
precipitate out and your pipeline as
well this is actually an image from one
of our lab equipment it's called a
rocking cell and what it does is it
rotates up and down but you fill it with
with gas with your actual hydrocarbon
gas and water and what you try to form
are these things called hydrates and
that's that little white ice like
structures they're basically the
interesting thing about them is that
they're they're very similar to ice but
they actually form above the water's
freezing temperatures so bottom of the
ocean floor is a couple degrees above
freezing so it's the perfect environment
for these with high pressures and that
ball in there as it rotates up and down
it moves back and forth and if it could
stop then you know you know kind of
qualitatively that you would have a
blockage in your line so so background
so so we as a company a couple years ago
we're kind of facing this challenge and
I think it's something that to some
level a lot of companies probably face
specifically engineering companies what
we had was we do all this modeling and
we had a lot of data that we have to
post process and for that we had a lot
of Excel spreadsheets to handle that a
lot of VBA macros and even one off kind
of executables and so it was very poorly
managed and we had we ended up having a
lot of different versions of different
things and it became really difficult to
find the right thing for the job and let
alone which version to use so what we
tried to do was we created this thing
which we which we called Alex and it was
named after the the the Library of
Alexandria and what it is is it sort of
attempts to kind of capture all those
utilities and a consistent and
maintainable way so I chose to do it in
the Wolfram language because of some
language flexibility and it's math
functionality it makes it really easy to
prototype things and develop them really
quickly so the calculations the majority
of it there's about 40 of them what 41
of them in there and their majority of
our calculations there's also a lot of
like workflow type things to help us
kind of simplify data and things like
that just to kind of give you guys a
quick quick
preview this is kind of what it looks
like but I'm just showing a few of them
here but some of them are really kind of
simple calculations and others of them
are actually very detailed so for
example this one right here is actually
let you build in insulation on a
pipeline and simulate a cool down time
which is if you were to shut in your
pipeline at time zero how long do you
have until you reach some temperature
that you're concerned about for hydrates
or relaxed or any type of issues so it's
using nd solve and it's pretty
sophisticated calculation actually
there's a lot of other things on our lab
side of things we have a lot of
equipment that we integrate with they
produce a lot of data and trying to make
sense of that data is something that we
have utilities to do as well like this
one for example we actually take a
sample oil sample run it through a
differential skill in calorimeter and we
can take that raw data and from that we
can get a wax precipitation curve which
is sort of what this is and as you as
you drop temperature how much wax do you
precipitate out of your oil sample so
there's a lot of integration both on the
engineering side and also on the on the
lab side of things that are at our
company so as we were kind of going
through this what kind of a came to a
point where we we realized that we where
was a few areas where we needed
something more we have a lot of we use a
lot of simulation software a lot of
thermodynamics software things like that
and all those a lot of them have the
ability to interface with them through
through different api's and things like
that and some of them are written in net
we also have plotting libraries that we
use to actually generate reports through
slides and things like that and so we
realized there was a need for us to kind
of look into some of this net' interface
and specifically netlink because alex
was already written in the Wolfram
language we wanted something to keep it
there as well so that was kind of where
where all this came from and I've
started to spend some time with that
link and I just kind of want to share in
this presentation what some of things
I've learned a lot of it is is going to
be in the documentation center if you
kind of dig for it but there's some
really good stuff in there and I think I
think it's worth talking about and were
kind of showing examples of so just real
quick I'm sure everyone hears heard of
dotnet before and
you probably no one could know more
about it than I do
but but it's basically the foundation
for most of Windows and the majority of
the programs at Windows you run on
nowadays key feature is that the
language can be compiled into dotnet
common language runtime so that's why
you have things like c-sharp net vb.net
c++ on that all these different language
is still running and then the dotnet
framework and then the other the other
nice feature now is that they're they're
quickly sort of starting to expand to
other platforms so now with things like
mono and marién things like that you can
run dotnet on on the Mac OS and on
another places so it's starting to get a
little bit of a broader reach to other
platforms as well which is kind of cool
to see so why do we need net so I
mentioned it in the last slide access to
things like forms and windows controls
and things like that that you might you
might want to have access to third-party
blll like sometimes you might have
sophisticated solvers or math related
functions that have already been written
in DLLs and you don't necessarily know
all the details of those to rewrite them
in the Wolfram language and so you just
want to be able to access them and then
there's other things like you know
interfacing with Excel and stuff like
that so I'll have to apologize for this
for the rest of this are kind of gonna
go through it very quickly just because
I want to kind of show you guys some lot
of examples real quick and so I might
kind of braise over some of the some of
the finer details but if you have any
questions you know feel free to grab me
and we could talk more about it or if
you have you know additional knowledge
and things to share as well I'm still
learning some of this as my some of this
myself as well so yeah
so this first part I'm just going to
show kind of some quick examples of how
you can call the Wolfram language from
dotnet so if you've got some application
that you're developing in dotnet
majority of what you're doing is on a UI
side of things and and really you just
want to call off the Wolfram language to
perform some calculation that you really
don't want to write yourself alright so
this would be an example where you would
do that you can create a link to the
math kernal so this is it's kind of a
snippet of c-sharp code you can create a
link to the math kernal and then you can
send your your your calculations through
a number of different ways kind of one
of the most common ones is this so math
Lane evaluate to output form and because
Wolfram language has a full form
functionality for everything you can
sort of do a full form on anything that
you wanted to do and then put it into a
string and then send that to the
computation yeah I don't know actually
yeah so yeah so if I run this so you can
see you know it works you'll see a
little math kernal pop up and the reason
for that is because I close it here so
it starts typing and closes if you
wanted to keep it persistent throughout
the application you can do that as well
and it probably be a lot faster to do
some of these and this in this example
I'm instead of evaluating two output
form I'm actually evaluating to an input
or to an image form and then so I can
then directly load that that image in
right here so just a few things to keep
in mind on this like I said this is
really more for you're building
something in net and you just want to
call it the Wolfram for for a few quick
calculations that's when you can use
this there's a couple dll's that have to
be present in your application directory
directory that's the Wolfram net link
dll and then these ml 32 or 64 I for
dll's okay so kind of moving to the rest
of the presentation is going to talk
about net link so just to introduce it
it's a technology integrated into
Mathematica and it allows for direct
communication with dotnet obviously you
have to have the dotnet framework or
some equivalent installed on your
computer but really the heart of it is
you know it gives the ability to work
with dotnet kind of the wolfram touch as
I like to say so one of those things one
of those benefits is that it lets you
work in a truly interpreted environment
so some real brief syntax to to get that
link you called it
you call needs net link you install the
net link now here I have an example of a
class so a class called person I have
two properties in here called first-name
lastname and I initialize those
properties through the constructor by
passing in those arguments so to create
that object within the Wolfram language
you use the function called net new and
I'm going to instantiate a new instance
of the person class calling it from this
dll where the code is actually contained
and then I'm going to pass in John Doe
and and it returns back this net object
and so in order to get access to those
properties within dotnet you can use
either the @ sign or the functional sign
exactly the same way you do any other
function with enough
so here's here's the kind of example to
to simulate one of those scenarios where
you might have some some function that's
already been written in dotnet DLL and
you and you need to just call out to it
so in this case I have a calculations
class it's got some really simple
function in here to perform addition
between a and B so I instantiate a new
instance of my calculations class and
then I can directly call that function
now perform addition passing two plus
two and returns back for one a little
bit more interesting example is you can
actually using this this variable in
here called standard link when you when
the Wolfram language creates a link to
net if it's done via that that path the
standard link actually gives you a link
back to the Wolfram language so in this
case I've got some function here I'm
gonna say what is the value of a and if
this standard link is gonna call back to
my actual Wolfram language kernel and
when I evaluate eight it's actually
gonna tell me what it is so if I say
okay a is some text create a new
instance of my my class and then I asked
what is the value of a it's gonna return
that and then of course if I change the
value of a it's gonna it's gonna give me
something value so kind of a way to get
back and forth communications between
Wolfram language and dotnet so to create
by default when you when you load when
you create windows within that you in
the Wolfram language you you can call
system that windows that forms that form
I think it is if you want to access WPF
which is the windows presentation
foundation you just need to first load
this net assembly which which is the
presentation framework DLL it's once
you've loaded that I'm going to create a
quick little function here that's going
to create a new system that windows that
window and then just assigned some some
height and width to it so now when I
when I show that I can see okay I've got
alive we've got a live window so that's
working just a few kind of special
assemblies lots of things can be loaded
via the load net type so in this case
you know I'm not going to run through
the
but there you can load this net type
windows startup location and I think
it's a new num and if I create a new
window I can actually specify that I
want that window to be in the center
screen using using the context syntax
okay so kind of got some of the kind of
fundamentals out of the way I wanted to
talk about what it means to kind of
truly to work in a truly interpreted
environment which is what netlink gives
you so if I create this this I've got
this new function here that's going to
create some content and I'm gonna put in
my window so I'm coming back here I
create a new WPF form I'm creating new
content for that form and then I'm
assigning the content to to that new
content that I create so now when I show
when I show this it's it's running its
are kind of put it off on the side here
now as opposed to a compiled language
where if I want to make changes I need
to take to stop the program make a
change recompile and then restart it
here if I load this net type for brushes
I can change the color of the
application immediately so now it
becomes like gray I can I can come down
here I can load a few other types so I
can specify alignments correctly create
a function that's going to give me a
button so of a type of system that
windows control button and here I'll
just set some of my line mints so that
it shows up a little bit better in the
window so I create that button and now I
say okay I'm gonna my original window
content had a doc panel so you can
access the children of that doc panel
and then you can go and add another
control to it so it's kind of the way
windows WPF works so now if I come back
here I got some button in there so I
didn't have to compile anything I didn't
stop anything at it and recompile which
is kind of neat similarly I can add a
text box kind of using the same idea and
then I've got some some blank text box
so these are really kind of basic
examples but just show you kind of
what's possible which is pretty cool
there's even functionality within net
within net link sorry
to add event handlers so if I create
some function called WPF func what
that's going to do is it's going to set
my textbox that I added the text
property to the date strange so if I
create that function and now I'm going
to add an event handler to that WPF
button when the click but when the click
event is triggered it's gonna call that
WPF function and so now I can go and see
if all this works so hopefully it does
it does so something kind of cool just
to show you what you can do in an
interpreted environment so okay so so
while that while that stuff is is really
cool and there's a lot you can do with
it certainly you're probably not going
to write an entire application in that
path right so I think you kind of need
some better way and this is where I'm
kind of at at this point and I'm kind of
looking for that better path better way
to do this if you're familiar with WPF
and dotnet you've probably heard of mvvm
which stands for model view viewmodel
it's basically a design architecture
where you try to isolate your UI in your
view from your model and your model
would be your business calculations your
your data you know your SQL queries
things like that and then in the in
between those you have this view model
that sort of acts as the interface
between the model and there's the view
and I'm definitely not an expert on this
but you can kind of get the gist of what
itwhat is trying to do and why it's
trying to do it right you want to
separate your UI as much as possible
from the business logic calculations so
if we were to do something like that in
the Wolfram language what would it look
like right and there's probably a number
of different ways that we can do this
I'm still kind of trying to figure out
the best way possible but I'll present
what I have right now so this is this is
just a screenshot from visual studio so
I'm designing some you know make-believe
application here and I'm really using
visual studio for what it's best at
right which would be designing this user
interface the code behind this I've got
this button and I'm going to create a
new object called call button 1 and then
in my constructor I'm going to set that
button 1 which is this actual control
equal to the
public property call button one so that
I have access to it so now if I come
down here and I create a new WPF form I
create a new instance of this example
window that I created it has a little
bit more in it you'll see then the
screenshot this is an old screenshot but
I can create that an instance of that I
can set the content and now I could show
it so okay so I've got I've got all that
done I've got the you I created on the
dotnet side of things but well from
language is really what's controlling
this so now if I create some function
here button one func it's just going to
print now we can add an event handler
it's when that button gets clicked it's
gonna call that function so now if I
come back here and say it's working
right everything's hooked up and it's
working so this is cool so what else
does is let does this let us do though
well let's just do a couple things
so let's Wolfram language do what it's
best at right which is computation logic
things like that
and then it lets net show some of the UI
side of things which is probably when
it's what it's good at as well if I
close this example and do a couple other
things so I'm going to recreate all that
now in my button one function I'm gonna
I have this status property within that
that UI as well and so now I can
actually set this status while the
calculation is performing I can I can
simulate some long withstanding
calculation and then I can I can set the
input and then I can change the status
of it back to ready so just to show you
what it looks like so it's running now
now I've changed some status so this
looks really basic but if you tried to
do something like this and dotnet it's a
lot more than than five lines of code
which is what you can do in the Wolfram
language side so it's pretty powerful
stuff similarly just just one one kind
of final example so okay so it lets the
Wolfram language do computations which
is great let's Wolfram language
interface with the UI which is great
what if we even let some of the UI logic
be performed by Wolfram language
all right so I'll run through all these
again now I've got some function in here
that's going to filter I have a list of
names it's going to show up in that last
text box and when you change the text on
there it's going to go through that
property access it do do a string
through a cases function on it find any
that are matching the string that I put
in and then filter the names on there so
and then I add an event handler this
time instead of clicked I got that I've
got a textbox in there and the event
that I'm that I'm linking this up to is
the text changed event so we get some so
here's some of the names so you can see
like if I start searching for Adam or
Navy and things like that right so this
is just an example to show you kind of
what what you can do you know in this
case I'm even letting Wolfram language
hanjo handle my UI logic so it's pretty
powerful stuff so just a few extra items
I kind of brushed over it in those last
examples but there's the difference
between show vs. show dialog on a window
if you want the Wolfram kernel to be
dedicated to to what you're doing on
the.net side make sure you use in show
dialog if you're on the windows form
instead of WPF it's sort of similar you
can call do net modal as opposed to do
net modal lists and all that's in the
documentation too if you want to look it
up lastly you need some way to debug and
you can do that so when you create a
link to net this program here called
installable net gets created and so in
Visual Studio your cash to go and attach
to that process and when you call
something from the Wolfram language and
you hit some breakpoint on your actual
code it'll work exactly like you would
any other program you could debug it so
kind of conclusions so like all of
Wolfram's technology and that link is a
really powerful tool if you are looking
for some application that just needs to
call the Wolfram language really quickly
you can do that if you're trying to do
something really advanced with dotnet
development consider prototyping it in
the Wolfram language or at least helping
you do some of the automation with the
Wolfram language so and lastly just you
know experiment with netlink that's kind
of how I've been learning some of this
stuff and
I think you'll find that a lot more as
possible than you might imagine any
questions yeah
yeah we have yeah we have some some
thermodynamic kind of simulators that we
use so we've automated some of the
process of kind of generating fluid
characterizations and things like that
like what a lot of what our workflow
will be is you kind of input as much as
you know about a particular oil sample
and then from that you have to generate
these massive kind of PBT tables which
would give you all that all those
characteristics at different
temperatures and pressures and then you
feed that into the simulation and so
we've kind of automated some of that
stuff with it we have some some plotting
libraries that we use that I would do in
the Wolfram language but it actually
these plotting libraries let you do
multiple at like a lot of different axes
so we can pair numerous different
variables at the same time so to
generate some of those plots we use the
netlink now so we have functionality to
do some of that with as well
I haven't having gotten into it a lot
yet but it yeah obviously some
definitely something to be we had to be
aware of and try and figure out the best
way to handle it yeah yeah yeah
yeah if they if they if those people
that produce those allow you to if they
have public api's or you know any other
things anything that's available that
you can interface with if they're in
Dannette or even even some older
components some older legacy type things
you can you can interface with that
through net link yeah yep I've been I've
been really impressed with with just
some of the interpreted environment type
of things so I'm really done anything
that's missing yet probably maybe as I
get into it a little bit more I might
have something else right right it was
written yep I haven't haven't seen
anything actually and the only the only
catch that you had to have was loading
that presentation framework DLL right
yeah yeah that's that's really it though
yeah I like I think WPF is a little
cleaner looking and a little bit more
modern so that's why I chose to use it
okay
[Applause]